uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
the russian troops
continued to destroy our infrastructure
they continue to fire at our towns uh in
harkev uh dunbas in sumer but
be sure we will rebuild everything we
will rebuild every street every town
every building every flat and every
ukrainian you can see they're really
trying here to get some food into people
when they arrive to get them warm at the
end of last week it was -10-12 and the
trains often don't run overnight so
people are literally stuck here
overnight as you can see they've got the
furnace going to there's an army of
volunteers and many of the people who
are running this area
have actually become refugees themselves
they've left places like kharkiv a week
or so ago they've decided to do their
bit trying to keep the heating going
because it's so cold for people
overnight here the business really
depends on whether a train has just
arrived often uh from the kiev region uh
you know that people will come from
khakim and they'll get to kiev and
they'll definitely fight their way on
another train and as you can see they
hold them back in barriers to try and
make this as controlled and calm a
process as possible but
lots of young children waiting for a
very long time to get here